tell a story with the modes of your PO I
know it sounds wild but the option of
doing this has recently become available
for Consumer level POI and I want to
show you how to do
it Drex here from Drex Factor Poise
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I want to lay
down some theory on how we can use LED
po modes and more specifically mode
changes to support our performances but
before we dive in I just want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys pyrot Tera
light toys and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
awesome companies and the work they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- buus friend
of the channel Becca beon thank you so
much for supporting my channel my work
and my mission at this point I've done
several videos on theory of performance
as it pertains to pois spinning but
there's one topic I've very notably not
explained in those videos and that's how
LED light modes can have an impact on
performance Glovers have been doing this
for more than a decade and there's an
extremely deep and detailed theory of
performance around changing light modes
on the fly to support gloving
performances let's talk about how to
write a great program and what you need
to think about in doing so this guide is
going to focus on single Pixel
programming rather than Graphics or
programmable poy but if you're
interested in seeing me produce a video
on either of those other topics as a
follow-up please let me know in general
I think that there are four specific
things to consider with the modes that
you're using in a specific program color
strobe brightness and special features
so let's dive in and take a look at each
one first though in a global sense I do
just want to pass on one piece of wisdom
that was passed on to me in working
through this process less is more the
more mode changes you put into a program
the less clear it will be that there's
an intention in the program at all at a
certain point all of those mode changes
become distracting rather than
supporting your performance that said
let's look at what will help support
your performance starting with
color color is one of the most powerful
tools we have for exploring ing human
emotion and there's no shortage of
resources out there on how color maps to
different emotions or triggers responses
in the human mind red can seem very
passionate angry loving or dangerous
green can seem sickly artificial envious
or disgusting blue can seem sad pensive
cold or lonely there's seriously no
shortage of written resources out there
on how colors influence human emotion in
a variety of ways I'll go ahead and link
to a couple that I found helpful down in
the description to get you started and
while we're talking about color that
means we should also talk about color
contrasts because if you're changing
modes between colors it helps to make
sure that people can actually tell that
the mode changed for instance if you
change from red to orange that change
may not read as well as changing from
red to blue greater contrast between
colors helps to clarify that the emotion
you're depicting has changed and
heightens the drama for the audience to
do this you want to switch your modes
between complimentary colors that is
colors that are across from each other
on the color wheel and therefore
contrast greatly with each other common
complimentary color sets include red and
grein orange and teal and yellow and
purple and yes if those color
combinations sound familiar it's because
they form the basis of movie lighting
and superhero costumes want an easy way
to pick two contrasting colors go pick
up a comic book of course it might
actually be your whole intention not to
let the mode change bring attention to
itself Maybe you'd like to slowly
transition the audience between a series
of emotions such that when they arrive
at a point where they do realize that
the colors have changed they're left
with a sense of disorientation or
confusion as to how they got there in
which case transitioning from red to
orange to Yellow to green and then
finally blue might not be the worst call
there's also one other aspect of color
to think about that for lack of a better
term I'm calling biology ever notice how
in submarine movies the lights are
always red that's not just because it
elevates the drama of these scenes
though that is true as well it's because
the human eye adapts more quickly to
total darkness if the light it's been
exposed to has a longer wavelength as it
does with red so if you're in a
performance environment where the LED
POI are the only source of Illumination
red light will relax the photo receptors
in your audience's eyes and green or
blue light will shock and Dazzle them
requiring a moment or two for them to
readjust this can be used to really
dramatic effect and frequently is in the
gloving world but bear in mind this only
works if there isn't another source of
Illumination in the same space if there
is then the eyes of your audience have
already adjusted to that light source
and this effect will not read just
something to keep in mind the venues in
which we perform have an impact on this
stuff too of course there's also
something to be said for color Fades or
multicolor modes that is modes in which
multiple colors are displayed in
sequence these can be excellent
opportunities to highlight several
emotions at the same time perhaps
drawing together the themes of your show
or displaying more complex emotions with
layers and Nuance again colors that are
similar are going to be harder to tell
apart than those that are complimentary
one trick I found for programming color
fade modes with two or more colors was
to have two colors that are relatively
similar to each other and then one that
contrasts with both to make it stick out
and make it clear that a fade mode is
being used your mileage may vary
according to your intention but in
general I'd say that you want to avoid
program pramming Fades that have all
colors that neighbor each other on the
color wheel if for no other reason then
it might not be clear that a color fade
is being used at all otherwise cool so
next up let's talk about
strobes strobes vary the length of time
the LEDs are turned on and off some can
create regular gaps in a pattern and
others can make the Poise Trails seem
cluttered and chaotic and of course a
strobe can be on constantly creating a
solid TR for the prop the first and most
important thing to bear in mind about
strobes is that they also reflect the
Precision of your movement if your
tricks are a little bit messy then that
will be made painfully clear if the
strobe mode is set to solid strobes that
leave gaps are much more forgiving to
the Precision of your trails and
patterns A Glover described things to me
as such use strobes with gaps in them if
the shape of the trail is important that
way the audience gets the best
impression of your patterns by
connecting the dots in their own heads
to create ideal forms of them use solid
strobes for moments of precision where
having attention riveted to one spot at
one time is important for emphasis in
addition I think strobes can tell us a
lot about how we're meant to identify
the State of Mind of the performer messy
strobes with overlapping colors convey a
feeling of anxiety franticness or energy
consistent strobes do much to calm down
the viewer but may also convey a certain
degree of uneasiness or a small degree
of anxiety solid strobes convey more
certainty decisiveness and and stability
all of these are tools that you can use
to convey emotional information to your
audience and give them Clues as to the
internal State of Mind of the character
that you're playing finally strobes can
also communicate a lot of information
about the energy of a piece especially
in the length of the gaps between lights
short gaps between lights to me feels
way more energetic and engaged longer
gaps start to feel lethargic and
disconnected at a certain point it
becomes impossible to determine if the
visible pieces of a trail are even truly
connected anymore this can be a great
way to suggest that the energy level in
a piece is winding down next up let's
talk about the brightness of the
prop to my mind brightness is really
good at conveying two specific pieces of
information to the audience Dynamic
shifts and focus having a PO go from
Bright to dim can say a lot about the
energy level or State of Mind of the
character that the performer is playing
but you know what really gets a whole
lot of attention going from dim to
Bright right away
this can be used to create instantaneous
Dynamic shifts akin to turning on a
distortion pedal for an electric guitar
you could also gradually dim or brighten
up the POI to suggest gradual changes
this specifically removes Dynamics from
the performance and makes different
pieces start to blend together you can
create interesting contrasts when a
performer seems very energetic but the
brightness of their prop seems to be
fading like colors this is also a tool
that can be used in dark performance
spaces to shock and Dazzle the
audience's eyes and create impactful
Dynamic shifts use this feature
sparingly though as too many shifts will
desensitize people to what's supposed to
be a very important moment I mean unless
that's your whole intention to begin
with brightness can also be used to
bring Focus to specific moments too
similar to how going from strobes with
gaps to solids can be used to draw
emphasis to specific moments so can
changes in brightness maybe there's a
beat that you really want to emphasize a
moment in the choreography you want to
stick out or an effect that you'd like
to emulate like a heartbeat brightness
can help emphasize all of these
different cases and others focus and
emphasis can sometimes help to highlight
a moment into piece that otherwise isn't
Landing or reading in the way you want
it to perhaps a moment of light
intensity is the way to go in order to
bring it
out finally in the world of LED props
there are some other special features
that don't easily fit into any other
category many of which are special
programming functions associ with
activating or deactivating an
accelerometer some of those modes
emphasize zero points that is stalls or
pendulums when the movement of the POI
seems to stall out entirely others
emphasize the POI beginning to move
drawing even more attention to the fact
that they are in motion your mileage on
these features will depend greatly on
how much you're using the specific kind
of Po movements that they react to but
in the best scenarios they can draw an
enormous amount of attention to moments
in your performance where you are
playing around with movement and
Stillness and in a variety of different
Fashions play around with these modes
and see what they bring up for you it
might be that there are moments in your
performance that can benefit from the
kind of emphasis that these reactive
modes have so we've talked a lot now
about a variety of different ways that
we can use mode changes in our po to
support our performances so now I want
to show you an example of this in action
earlier in the year I choreographed a
piece and wrote a program to go with it
that emphasizes different aspects of
this performance I wrote this piece
around my very complicated feelings of
connecting with the world after
quarantine and just how much it felt
like the world and the people in it had
radically changed as a result of the
pandemic I broke my performance up into
several sections based upon what emotion
I wanted to convey red for anger yellow
for
excitement green for
disgust and blue for sadness or
depression as much as possible I tried
to choose changes in color modes that
were going to have the greatest contrast
from each other to emphasize my own es
an emotional state I mainly used strobes
with gaps in them to convey my own
anxieties around reconnecting with the
world and overall feeling as though I
and all of us are still figuring things
out there is one and only one moment in
the piece where the strobe mode switches
to solid and is to emphasize a lot of
emotions all happening at once I created
a section in which the PO dim and then
turn back on to maximum brightness to
emphasize emerging from my quarantine
cocoon and the excitement of
reconnecting with people and now without
further ado my performance of big sad
[Music]
enjoy come and sleep with me when those
was lose the innocence it might be right
if I
me we can't get ahead they said I am so
delusional hope that might be
wrong if I be
me you're sting right I'm at Hot Shot
bend the shot hasn't hit you yet and
like a
twitch I'm so on and off again it's hard
to believe
myself and I reg
gr I am not who I want to be it hurts so
badly it's what you day with the offet
hopefully live so
happily sometimes they want to
freaking where I am I give in I'm big
sad sometimes I want to be ride for no
reason and I just see the riding on the
[Music]
wall sometimes I want to
break where I am
I give in I big sh sometimes I want to
see I
know and I just see the riding on the
wall sometimes I want to break it where
I am I get in I'm big sad sometimes I
want to see right for no
reason and I just see the riding on the
wall sometimes I want to again
where I am I can I just see the riding
down the wall I want to see right for no
reason and I just see the riding on the
wall sometimes I want to break
[Music]
it I give in I'm big sad sometimes I
want to see
right and I just see the riding on the
wall
and I just see the riding on the
[Music]
wall and I just see the riding of the
wall I get where I am I get I'm big S
[Music]
cool so I really enjoyed writing that
program and I hope you all enjoyed
watching it most of the information
featured in this video was based on
already existing sources of info on
gloving and Theatrical lighting I'm
going to link to a bunch of the sources
that I consulted down in the description
and a big thank you in particular to
Peter Howard of the gloving Paradigm for
his excellent video detailing the light
programming philosophy of impacting and
Christian Park for his direct to on this
topic you both are awesome did you get
anything out of this video please make
sure to like comment share and subscribe
to help other people find it and to help
my channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without the very helpful support of all
of these wonderful people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon they and the people listed down
in the description help to make this
video and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very generous support and if you out
there watching are not currently a
supporter but you like to become one you
can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com factor poy and signing up
there you can get access to a whole host
of awesome rewards and even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world do check
that out please and thank you if you'd
like to check out some of my reviews for
Led po products over the years including
my first impressions of the flow toys
Connect app I'll include a link to a
playlist of those videos down in the
description or up on screen if you're
watching this video on YouTube thanks so
much for watching make sure to get out
and flow today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon take care peace